ich finde bei der Klimakrise können wir
tatsächlich dauerhaft jedes Jahr mit
einer neuen Notlage argumentieren jetzt
bei der Ukraine und wir haben ganz klar
gesagt wir stehen an der Seite der
Ukraine wir geben diese Gelder weit wir
unterstützen militärisch finanziell
humanitär wenn eine neue Situation steht
und das kann tatsächlich passieren es
wurde gerade ein Beispiel genannt wenn
die US-Amerikaner sich zurückziehen was
dramatisch wäre aus meiner Sicht für die
geopolitische Lage aber wenn das
passieren sollte dann werden wir handeln
und dann werden wir finanzieren dann
werden wir auch die Notlage ausrufen wir
sehen gerade keine Notlage mit Blick auf
die Ukraine wenn sich die Situation
verändert werden wir handeln dann gibt
es auch die Möglichkeit von dem 115 als
eine Notlage auszurufen und wir werden
die Koalition dann nicht verlassen ich
glaube auch dass unser Partner nicht tun
wird